you can get back from the concert till
midnight you promised you were gonna get
up early so you could bike to work take
back slow no taking it back connect a
Japanese helmet on you come on rise
shine dude pick it up what if it's that
new job offer wait it could be Ashley
hello mom hey that's the work way of
saying hello it's probably your mom's
work phone hey hey how's that good
donuts donuts you just took a bike to
work don't kill the vibe I get out
something we could just go home early
and order some Chinese food hold up I
got it great let's hit it yeah this is
great you really liked her you did text
her back the medium oh no we should wait
three days we need to really analyze
what to say next what if she thinks a
memorial cars like to be ignored just
stop listening to this guy and listen to
your gut I'm testing her back you don't
know not heart but like lips alien
aliens was it yeah 30 back yeah yes
right cactus just go home and play video
games yo what dude it's ashley she wants
to hang out of some beach party let's go
well if you're awkward we don't like
rejection hate it you kidding me you're
great you've been biking more you've
been eating better you're killing it
thank you we're going to get out of this
total traffic jam
you